[Music]
an artist paintbrush can have synthetic
bristles or natural ones made of animal
hair which type to use is really a
matter of the artists preference however
painters often tend to use a natural
brush for watercolors a synthetic brush
for acrylics and either type for oils
these natural hair paint brushes are
made of red sable which is tailed hair
from a species of weasel red sable is
renowned for its softness and for
spreading paint Findley and evenly an
experienced head maker performs the
initial steps of making the head of the
paintbrush she unrolls and straightens
out a bundle of red sable then separates
enough hairs for one brush of this size
she inserts the hairs into a metal band
called a ferrule made of nickel-plated
brass she feels how they fit in the
ferrule if the fits too tight she
removes some hairs if it's too loose she
adds some brushes of different shapes
required different tensions the head
maker takes the correct brass mold for
the brush shape she's making and inserts
the hairs all the way down into the mold
cavity
[Music]
she ties the roots of the hairs together
with the string
then removes them from the mold she
inserts the brush head back into the
Pharaoh
then removes the strain
[Music]
next using a template she adjusts what's
called the length out of the brush head
length out is how far the hairs protrude
from the end of the ferrule
after removing stray hairs she aligns
the end of the ferrule with the edge of
the nearly 1 inch long template and
pulls out or pushes in the hairs until
their tips align with the opposite edge
of the template
[Music]
she completes her specialized work by
suspending the assemble brush head from
a rack another worker now fills a
syringe with epoxy glue then with the
syringe fills the ferrule with enough
glue to submerge the hairs once the glue
has dried overnight another worker taps
the brush head against a strip of
adhesive tape to remove any short hairs
that didn't adhere she dips the hairs
into a solution of starch and water and
works the solution into all the hairs by
massaging the head on a towel the starch
allows the hairs to be trained to a
permanent shape she makes this
particular pointed shape by spinning the
head then smoothing the hairs with her
fingers
the starch dries overnight locking in
the shape to make the paintbrush handle
a worker in search birch dowels in a
pegboard then mounts the board upside
down on a dipping machine this machine
submerges the dowels in black lacquer
paint after one day of drying time
there's a second dip partway this time
and silver paint the machine has
markings to indicate how deep to dip the
dowels for each color
[Music]
after another day of drying time there's
a third dip this time partway in black
paint this creates a black handle with a
silver stripe once the last coat of
black paint dries a worker uses a pad
printer to stamp lettering on the handle
with quick dry silver ink one stamp
simultaneously applies the
manufacturer's name the brush share
material the size of the brush and the
series number
[Music]
a worker clues the brush head onto the
handle then the worker sets the brush
aside for a couple of hours until the
glue partially dries to a tacky state
because the next step
crimping would crack the fully dried
hardened glue
the worker inserts the ferrule into a
crimping machine which has been loaded
with a die that's the correct diameter
for this brush handle the machine crimps
the ferrule tightly to the handle
attaching it permanently
once that glue hardens the paintbrush is
finally ready from this point onward
it's in the artist's hands
[Music]